[Music]
the west mission in afghanistan was
clearly a failure
but what exactly went wrong as former
british defense ministers campaigned for
greater support of afghans who helped
the war effort
andy owen a former intelligence officer
who spent time in the country
writes in this week's issue that the
west never understood afghanistan enough
he joins me on spectator tv now together
with dr mike martin
who spent two years as a british army
officer in helmand
andy mike thanks for coming on now andy
you write about the lessons we learned
from our war in afghanistan
and that when you were there you saw
there was no clear or measurable
strategy
what was that like on the ground before
sort of the answer about the strategy i
think when we're talking about
afghanistan at the moment it's really
important to recognize
the 40 000 at least afghan civilians
who've died the 3500
coalition troops 450 of them british who
died
as well as the acts of bravery that were
committed there as well
and and recognized that it is really
tough to talk about the failures
because certainly um the the relatives
who had loved ones who have died there
do not want to feel that they
died in vain but it is really important
to recognize the failures and we owe it
to
the next generation of soldiers and the
next generation of civilians
who may be impacted if we make the the
same mistakes again
and for me one of the biggest mistakes
was that that that lack of a clear
measurable consistent strategy on the on
the ground in afghanistan and there's
one good example to illustrate that was
um one day sitting in the in the
headquarters
in um of the coalition down in um in
helmand in lashka
the the brigade commander had been
visiting a district
only the day before and had been talking
to some of the farmers there
who were growing opium and he had
assured them he wasn't interested in
their opium he was interested
in in dealing with the with the taliban
there and if they didn't support the
taliban
he wouldn't touch their opium and then
the next day when we were sitting there
a task force from kabul flew down in
in their white hind helicopters landed
sponsored by the the foreign office and
destroyed the opium crop there because
they were part of the canter narcotics
task force and our strategy at different
points was focused on
trying to originally get rid of the the
architects behind 911
it was then also trying to get rid of
the taliban it was
dealing with the opium problem there
trying to cut off the opium supplies
and then ultimately sort of driven by a
flawed and hubristic
ideology trying to give the non-existent
nation state of afghanistan a western
liberal democracy and supplant that on a
very different culture that had its had
its own system of governance and
and really a very local tribal based way
of
interacting and mike this is something
that you've picked up on
as well in the past you've written about
how the bus was funneling money into the
afghan government as well as into the
pakistan government and
you point out that this is a ridiculous
strategy can you talk us through why
that's so contradictory
uh sure well the uh uh
obviously afghanistan and pakistan are
neighbors and they share a border
um that the brits in fact um drew
in in 1893 and um
it's it's pretty commonly accepted
that the pakistani government and
particularly the pakistani military
supports the afghan taliban and they
support them
militarily with supplies but also with
advisors
and and with the rest area you know you
can go back across the border
your family are safe perhaps you can go
to hospital if you've been injured
so you know the pakistani state we need
to be very clear
are a major supporter of the afghan
taliban
now of course pakistan is
a poor country and it's also a strategic
and important country
and so over the last 50 years but let's
just deal with it since 911 over the
last 20 years
um america and the um brits and other
countries have funneled
billions of dollars into pakistan in the
way of
you know development projects but also
in the way of kind of arms deals
so we've sold them weapons and we've
given them weapons
and some of that is because they've been
conducting operations in their own
countries but of course there is
inevitably leakage so you know to come
back to the point of your question
we have spent the last 20 years in
afghanistan supporting the afghan
government
to fight the taliban who are an
insurgent movement who threaten that
government
but at exactly the same time we have
been
paying billions of dollars to the
pakistani government
whilst they have been sending that money
back across the border to the afghan
taliban
who have then used it to blow up british
soldiers
and that sounds like a very
bold way of stating that but that's
exactly
what has been happening british
government money
american government money has been
through this cycle via the
pakistani government via groups that we
lump together and we call the afghan
taliban and have been blowing up
british and american soldiers and
to us that seems utterly insane well to
the helmandes
where we were where andy and i were in
the south the country or see afghans
it is beyond insane and so
they try and explain
this evidence that they have in front of
them and the only way
that they can explain this evidence is
is they come to the following conclusion
they conclude
that the brits and the americans are
working with the pakistanis and the
taliban
to destroy the afghan states
and this sounds like a crazy conspiracy
theory indeed when i
first heard it i thought wow this is up
there with uh
you know 911 didn't happen or the moon
landings were faked it is a
very very very
common idea or concept that afghans have
that explains the last 20 years of the
war in afghanistan
that's fascinating mike andy how much do
you think that the west
understands what those conversations are
happening uh on the ground between
afghan people like how much
um is our failure down to a lack of
understanding of the afghan history
culture and
what is happening on the ground i think
it's a very significant part
part of our failure i think it um i
think we had very little understanding
of the
underlying culture i think um if you
just look at
how difficult it was to even communicate
with um
the people we were interacting with very
very few people spoke the
the local language pashtun down there um
we struggled to find military
interpreters
i think we'll struggle to find military
interpreters again in the future because
of the way we've treated some of the
afghans who did work for us uh and
we didn't understand the the the many
many local conflicts that we were
getting involved in
there was some of the the wider strategy
that mike has
has uh very clearly outlined there that
i think we were ignorant to
but also on a very local level we were
sucked into
many many local feuds pre-existing foods
that were
fighting and bubbling away way before we
got there
and we were walking into an environment
we didn't understand and a conflict we
didn't understand and i think
at the end of the day we were fighting a
different war to many of the afghans
who were on the ground that were
fighting and
mike let's talk about some of course
just add on to that would that be okay
because i i was one of the few people
who spoke
fluent [ __ ] and i was a political
officer and my job was to try and figure
some of this stuff out
and i um went just to illustrate and
reinforce andy's point
i went to the british library to pull up
the
records of the british political
officers who of course
um were operating in kandahar and in
helmand
throughout the 1800s and this was in
2011 i did this this was for the
research for my phd
um i said as these as these records came
up from the stacks
i just casually asked the librarian
the last time they'd been you know when
was last time someone pulled these out
1992 was the answer
and so at that point um uk
had been in afghanistan for 10 years and
we'd been
in hellmann for five or six years
and nobody had bothered to go the five
tube stops between
where the mod main building is and where
the british library is
in order to do some of the research from
the
previous british contingents uh who'd
been in helmand
and of course that you think eighteen
hundred's got us ages ago who remembers
that well
we didn't remember any of it but the
helmandes
um who are well more than half of her
manager illiterate when we went there it
was about 10 literacy
um they all remembered it and they all
knew
who fought the british at that time and
in fact they revered
the leaders who led the rebellions
uh if we can call them that against the
british at that time and this is how
little
we understood the conflict i think this
is a very similar story across asia as
well i'm chinese myself and
you know in east asia i think that's a
similar story of british involvement
british
amnesia about what happened but local
memory as well and andy on that china
point one thing that you point out in
your piece is that
for our next foreign engagement and you
point out that
if we're happening we're going into cold
war too that we need to understand
china better and i don't really see that
many chinese speakers around westminster
either so i don't really think those
lessons have been learned what do you
think
i i would agree uh and i would hope and
this may sound
um extreme but i would hope that at
staff college
people are learning about confucianism
they're learning about the history
of china especially the british
involvement there which
the chinese population very much does
remember
um not least the opium wars uh and
really understand
how um the the chinese think and and i
don't think we are doing that
and it's not about the the traditional
know your enemy so you can defeat your
enemy it's also about creating those
opportunities for de-escalation
and creating those opportunities to not
go to war in the first place
and mike finally i couldn't have you on
the show with and let you go without
asking you about
the taliban this is something that
you've done a lot of writing about and
how there's no such thing
as the taliban can you explain why you
know there is a problem with politicians
in the media and
people in general talking about the
taliban
yeah i mean thanks for giving me the
opportunity to do that
uh not not many media organizations do i
guess the spectator is on the way up
um thank you we you know as human beings
we use labels right
we use them all the time so if i say you
know the word government
that will mean something different
depending on where you live on the
planet
where you are on the left right spectrum
for instance right
and the reason labels are so important
is because they then a concept pops into
your head
and i i would argue that when
you say the word taliban most people
think of
the kind of previous taliban government
um the de facto government from 9
6 2001 so it's kind of a cohesive
organization they've got some ministries
they've got an army
uh you know they ban music all that kind
of islamist stuff they you know
bad towards women and women have to wear
special shoes so they don't make noise
so we've got this kind of idea about
what the taliban are like but but the
most important bit of that idea
i would argue or the most dangerous bit
of the idea is that they are
a cohesive organization that is
able to operate in the same way as say
i don't know the labour party in the
united kingdom
okay well arguably
but they are
know your audience but they are not
um they are not at all and so i can
go through maybe three ways in which
they're not um
there's a political office of the
taliban at the moment
uh in doha and these are the guys who
negotiated
the agreement with the americans in
february 2020 that's led to this
pull-out which is why we're having the
kind of situation we've got going on now
right and the other people who met the
chinese recently as well
yeah absolutely absolutely i mean this
is what's dominating the news at the
moment
and then we have of course the military
wing who are doing a lot of the fighting
uh in afghanistan there's a huge amount
of divergence between those two
and you know daily you can see
statements coming from the political
wing and actions coming from the
military ring that are totally
um uh discordant so it could be a ruse
but actually i think the political wing
has totally lost control political
bringing mostly from the old taliban
from the regime
96 2001. the military wing
some of these guys some of the fighters
weren't even born when 2001 happened
secondly we have um the this idea that
um actually the the taliban is a kind of
franchise
of lots of different uh interest groups
and
this is not hugely unusual i mean we do
see it in political parties you know
the conservatives might have in them say
free marketeers
and people who are culturally
conservative for instance right
and so you know the party tries to hold
them together but in
the taliban we've got really really
marked
factionalism between um already
established insurgent groups so like the
haqqanis that were insurgents well
before the taliban
we've got the helmandi taliban who are
basically locals they're sangonites and
they've got connections to iran
we've got the guys in kandahar well
they're really strongly connected to
pakistan
up in head art that's a totally
different thing
so we have a huge regionalization
uh behind um what we see
and then the third type of factionism
i'd like to bring up is is really
what i explored when i was in helmand so
as i know as
as i told you i spent some time as a
political officer i then did my phd down
there
um and i picked apart
all of the reasons why people were
fighting and most of the reasons why
people
were fighting were not to establish an
islamic emirate in fact i don't think i
met anyone who was that's fighting
to establish an islamic emirate the
people were fighting because of
water or they had a feud with a police
chief and this is some of the stuff andy
was bringing up
some of the conflicts we stumbled into
or because
it was a revenge killing because their
brother had been killed by coalition
forces or the canal was in the wrong
place or
or or or so there's a huge multiplicity
of reasons
village to village family to family
about why people pick up a kalashnikov
to solve their problems because
there's no effective court system in
afghanistan so the only way you can
solve your problems
is with a kalashnikov and so we've got
these three
levels of factionalization between
political and military
between different big factional
insurgent groups in different areas of
afghanistan
and right at the micro level between
different villages different families
different sub clans and it's really hard
to call
that a cohesive movement that that
concept
is not the same as the concepts that we
described at the beginning when i said
taliban and we thought about the 96 to
2001
taliban with ministries and an army and
so on and so forth
and the reason that's really important
is because as we go forward
everyone is now saying guys we've got to
stop fighting
we've got to sit down in doha the afghan
government and the taliban have got to
sit down and they've got to hammer out
some kind of
transitional government or something you
know we've got to have pizza how are we
going to do this what's the process
but how can you make
peace with a movement that is so
fractured
and i i worry that we're hanging our
hats on a process that's doomed to fail
because the taliban
this concept of the taliban is not
actually
what we think it is andy owen
mike martin thanks for joining spectator
[Music]
tv
[Music]
you